[Music]
what do we do cap
we
[Music]
fight is gonna end well
they're not stopping neither are we
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
we're still friends right since i don't
hardly hit me
[Music]
you're pulling your punches
[Music]
i didn't kill your father then why did
you run
[Music]
[Music]
that thing does not obey the laws of
physics at all kid there's a lot going
on here that you don't understand stark
said you'd say that
[Music]
he also said to go for your legs
[Music]
quick can you get him off me buckled in
yeah no i'm good i'm good arrow guy
let's go let's go
[Music]
[Music]
anything else that you're wrong
you think you're right
it makes you dangerous
[Music]
guess he had a point
you got hard kid
where you from
queens
brooklyn
[Music]
friday we have some weapon systems
offline what oh you gotta you're gonna
have to take this into the shop who's
speaking it's your conscience
we don't talk a lot these days freddie
deploying fire suppression system
uh
oh boy
[Music]
you